A local hospital is holding
a raffle as a fundraiser.
The individual cost of
participating in the raffle
is given by the following
expression-- 5t plus 3,
or 5 times t plus 3,
where t represents
the number of tickets
someone purchases.
Evaluate the expression when t
is equal to 1, t is equal to 8,
and t is equal to 10.
So let's first
take the situation
where t is equal to 1.
Then this expression
right over here
becomes-- and I'll use that
same color-- becomes 5 times 1.
5 times 1 plus 3.
5 times 1 plus 3, and we know
from order of operations,
you do the multiplication
before you do the addition.
So this will be 5
times 1 is 5 plus 3,
and then this is
clearly equal to 8.
Now let's do it when
t is equal to 8.
So when t is equal to 8,
this expression becomes--
and I'll do the same colors
again-- 5 times 8 plus 3.
Same color of green.
And once again, 5 times 8 is
40, and then we have the plus 3,
there so this is equal to 43.
And so we have the
last situation,
with t is equal to 10.
I'll do that in blue.
So we have 5 times 10.
So 5t is 5 times 10.
Instead of a t, put a 10 there.
5 times 10 plus 3.
That's a slightly
different shade of green,
but I think you get the idea.
5 times 10 is 50.
We do 50, and then we're going
to have to add 3 to that,
and that is equal to 53.
And we're done.